à peine levé les restrictions de
circulation la loire à vélo reprend du
service
plébiscité entre deux confinement l'an
dernier l'itinéraire semble promis un
nouveau record de fréquentation cet été
des pionniers se sont déjà lancés dans
ce long périple
c'est un projet de 700 kilomètres donc
partie de sancerre prennent au vert
jusqu'à la baule le croisic exactement
voilà au bord de l'atlantique
l'appel du large à bicyclette est
compatible avec le respect des mesures
sanitaires
notre trio a ajouté l'autonomie à son
voyage faute de restaurants ouverts sur
leur route
en outre le muscat bien c'est tout on
arrive au total de talent tout est prêt
tout ceci bien quoi on a besoin de
réserver donc si on est conscient que
millions noté concert on n'a plus 20 km
de plus et partir plus loin c'est bien
ça change du confort habituel absence de
dénivelé le fleuve sauvage à vos côtés
la loire à vélo n'est pas un grand défi
sportif
mais c'est quand même laventure derrière
le guidon c'est pas une grande aventure
ont parfois en afrique ou dans la jungle
mais mais ça reste pour des citadins
comme nous entre guillemets bon ça reste
ça reste une petite aventure sévère il
ya des jolies petites maisons
voilà la loi c'est ya du sable
la reprise d'activité de la restauration
et la réouverture des châteaux de la
loire devrait bientôt ajouter patrimoine
et gastronomie dans les attraits de cet
itinéraire cyclotouristique